cool yeah so thanks everyone for joining
so my colleague must and I will be
presenting how to
improve like your search engine results
using large language
models so Mustafa and I are both uh
machine learning Engineers for Walmart
and e-commerce site in the United
States so um this is the um link to the
GitHub
so uh if you want to follow along with
their notebooks or um yeah and we also
have a link uh link to a pdf version of
the slides um yeah at the root of the
repo we'll go uh go through some of the
setup uh there may be some issues with
setting up the notebook completely so
during this session like we'll uh like
we wanted to cover a lot of material so
we may not be able to run all the
notebooks live but we'll look at some
the rendered
output um yeah so this is the link I I
shared it also in the resources but it's
just uh this user ID and this is
the this is the
REO so you know who's the audience for
today you know uh uh the audience Who
members who will gain the most values
are like you know if if you consider
your like a beginner in the large
language model space if you're a
beginner in the search space you know so
if you don't have any prior knowledge uh
if you're looking for like how to
actually apply llms in a you in a uh in
a practical use case um if you're
already familiar with you know libraries
like Lan chain Rag and if you already
fin tune your own llms uh you may not
get much value from this session but
hopefully there's still some new things
that you might learn
so I would say this uh session has about
maybe like five sections so after after
most of those uh sections there is like
a
small uh jup notebook um so um we'll be
running it like inside our environment
but it may not completely run in collab
so definitely do
um uh you know feel free to run it low
or in collab externally but we'll just
be going through the notebook line so
yeah so that's about five um sections
here you know we'll introduce the space
of like what is the what is what are the
problems with e-commerce search how can
you know just like a very brief rushed
overview of large language models for
someone who might be new to the space um
and you know how you can use something
like prompting to talk to your large
language model and how can you find you
in your own large language model and
then we'll close the section with kind
of seeing about how other companies in
the e-commerce space are using
llms um again after each section there's
like a notebook that we'll be going over
and after each section we'll also pause
for any
questions so again we hope to take away
that you have from this section is you
know understand the e-commerce space you
know what are like the NLP problems that
exist there how you can use LMS to solve
some of those problems like a practical
application of how you can use like a
library like lanching to talk to some of
these llm providers and the results of
like a pre-train llm versus something
that's fine-tuned for your um for your
own use case
so yeah let's get started on the
intro so I would say like in an
e-commerce search space there may be
four
problems um and I have a diagram that
kind of illustrates these problems so
let's just go to these problems
directly so the first thing I would say
is like understanding the intent of a
user's query you know let's say you go
to Amazon or Walmart or whatever
e-commerce retailer and you type
something like red Nike men shoes 10
in like you want like the back end or
the vendor to basically understand that
this user is talking
about these certain type of attributes
you know the they're looking
for shoes and looking for shoes the
shoes has to have the color red the
brand has to be Nike and the size has to
be 10 in so that's one side you know
understanding the intent from the query
side you have the same happening on the
item side
um uh you may use the same models that
you have been using on the query side or
you may build custom models that be
might be running on the item
side so now that you have like uh you
understand the intents of the query and
uh at the item side now you need
to figure out um
like is this item relevant for the query
so you know for this query red Nike men
shoes um like the uh you know the first
shoes over there you know it is red and
it is shoes but it's not for the it's
not for the male
gender um so that's obvious that this
item is definitely not
relevant um you know the item the second
image here you know um there's some
green but I would say mainly the shoes
is kind of on the red color so this item
is
relevant
um uh this socks uh um this the socks
item you know like it matches three of
the four intent of the user but you know
the product type is not
socks um what about um the the last item
right so it is um it is red it is male
it is shoes um but the brand is not Nike
you know is that an issue um maybe the
user explicitly asked for Nike so um
they do want they do they do want Nike
shoes what happens if the shoes was like
11 in but it was a Nike shoes is that
relevant or not so depending on the
context um like even if like some of the
attributes match um the item may not be
considered relevant
um so we covered query understanding
item understanding query item relevance
and the last problem that I would say
that we would kind of cover about is
like um queries with like ambiguous
intents so you know like you as a user
if you go to Amazon and you see like
Christmas gift ideas you know when you
search for like query as ambiguous as
this you know you're also looking for
inspiration
or gift ideas right so in order to kind
of make sure like these items match to
the query you know like these Merchants
who upload their uh items on on these
e-commerce sites they kind of like stuff
the title right so you see like this
Rose uh the first image of like a
butterfly and a rose in a cage um like
like there's so many so many tokens or
so many terms in the title right uh you
know it's like for women mom Christmas
birthday gifts you know Grandma like
everything is put there right and I find
the second example a little bit
interesting too like you know this is a
non-stick skillet but if you look at all
the way at the end of this you know it
says ideal Christmas
gift um I don't know I mean I'm
surprised to learn like a skillet is a
good Christmas gift but um you know like
the seller of this item wants to make
sure it matches for this query so they
decided to um add um add that term at
the end of the title on the Amazon
listing um here's another example of
like I would say like an ambiguous
intent um so zero waste Oral Care right
so here like what is the user searching
for you know like are they searching for
like toothbrushes are they looking for
like zero toothpaste tablets um or are
they looking like for fla um so this
again like an example where like if you
just go with like matching like the
tokens that may be in the query and the
item title you may not come up with like
a good good enough
approach so just reiterating the four
problems that we talked about so the
first one is understanding the intent of
a user's query understanding the intent
of an item
understanding if a query and item pair
is relevant and for cases where you like
you have an ambiguous queries or like
the item titles suffers from a lot of um
you know title stuffing how can you how
can you match those
intents so we know the problems and you
know they're very they're pretty
Advanced and Rich um systems there but
you know let's take a very naive
approach for solving this problem you
know so let's say this is not an
e-commerce query but you know let's take
this query here of like pictures of kid
and playing right so there's normally a
flow that goes when this query is
processed you know you might the query
might come into your system like as a
string but you might decide to split the
tokens by Whit space um afterwards you
know you see like some terms like the
word off you know because it's kind of
like a common term you might remove them
right then the next thing you might do
is like you know there's the word
playing it becomes play right so you
remove the suffixes right you might stem
the words right
so this four token um query now is like
a three token query and it um it kind of
is a little bit different from before
you know playing became play and then
you know you search your catalog for
which items might contain that token so
um you know the first document or first
item has the word playing so it kind of
matches with play the second document
has the word kitten so that kind of
matches um document three you know it
technically has all the terms but you
know the document is longer it's not
talking about just kittens you know it's
the kitten is not playing the kitten is
sleeping it's a dog who's playing so it
technically contains all the tokens but
is it really relevant um to the qu
so yeah so the data set that we'll be
going over in uh today's section is like
a actual e-commerce shopping data set
that's provided by
Amazon so um yeah let's kind of get
started here um so as I mentioned like
before the lab I we did notice some
issues with collab so we'll go over the
notebooks again um and like we'll run it
live but you may face some issues so um
so in the notebook here like we do have
the binder link and um so if you click
on it um you will be taken to an
environment but just in the interest of
Time cover materials like we'll we'll be
grunning it from in one of our
environments just to kind of show the
materials but we will be running it live
um yeah so let me run this notebook look
um so uh at the root of the
repo uh this is the repo that kind of
sets of things so uh you know we just
clone the repo inside the repo we have
some requirements we'll go over like
some of the core packages that we're
using but it's mainly like using Lang
chain and um Lang chain and support
talking to other llms such just some of
the dependencies there required for that
and they'll be installing like elastic
search so elastic search is um search
engine system that it's open source that
allows you to kind of build like a
simple you know full text search engine
system so we'll look at the results that
um so in collab if you want to set
elastic search this is how you might do
this and this how you might start
elastic search in the background so in
in our
envirment um here oops sorry it looks
like I didn't start classic s maybe let
me um do this now so
so we have already dependency let
me start so elastic search can take some
time to start so that's why we just have
like a a Time block of just waiting for
a minute um and um so just to kind of
speed up some things like like we
provided like our cleaned version of the
data set so if you go into notebooks
you'll see like um the notebooks with
zero are like like some of the
pre-processing that we did on the data
set just in the interest of time
um yeah so but for most of the notebook
we'll be looking at this cleaned input.
parking
so yeah maybe while this is running let
me briefly show let's look at what the
data might look like
so um so as you know as you might think
like in an e-commerce data set we have
queries and items right so um so here
you have like this query like a privacy
fence this is the product ID so the ID
that Amazon uses to uniquely identify an
item in their
catalog um so how how do you know if
Aquarian item is relevant in this case
Amazon sent these Aquarian item pairs to
their human annotators to see if the
item is relevant or not so how can an
item be considered relevant you know
like the human reviewer would look at
the query would look at the item title
and then make that judgment call here um
a item can have a lot of metadata Amon
only provides like the brand and the
product color as a metadata um yeah
let's see if elastic
searches so elastic search is running
this is just a health check to make sure
it's working so you know we just showing
elastic search you kind of set like a
baseline like for a simple text BAS
system it's not important to understand
how things
work yeah so the last is working
um this is O sorry let me run this
notebook
again
um so this is actually a very rich data
set so Amazon has English queries uh
Spanish queries uh Japanese queries and
they also have like a subset of they
have a subset of um their catalog in
those regions so I believe there's like
more than a million or so query item
pairs
so this is the example we saw um for our
session today we'll mainly look at the
query and we'll look at the product
title and the relevance
label and to kind of
um make things so as I mentioned this
data is pretty rich so you know we do
have a lot of so a lot of human rating
collected for qu item there so it's a
rich data set if you're interested in
e-commerce so let's look at um some
some some of the results that we're
getting with a simple Baseline so in
this so this is like what um so not
Baseline so here we're looking at the
ground rout so in this case this are
these are results that Amazon's human
annotators marked as relevant or not
given the query so this uh airpod
casecute you know unfortunately Amazon
didn't really provide images with this
data set valid images so uh not all of
them might have images but let's just
click on this item here so by the rating
it's considered a human an found this
item as exactly relevant so I see this
is a Apple airpods caring case and you
know I think this is in the color and
the material looks kind of
nice
so um
so most of the top items like you know
they're consider exactly relevant but if
you look at some of these items here so
let me just bring this item here so this
is an air tag keychain for Apple Air
Apple Air tags so the user is
specifically looking for uh an airpod U
sorry an airpod case but this is more
like an accessory for uh an airpod so
that's why this item is not considered
relevant or maybe partially relevant
complement in this
case so you know let's play with some
more queries here so let's look at this
Adidas shoes men 15 inch
so
um you know the top items that we see
here you know it's Adidas it's men's
it's 15 inch so these items capture the
intent of the query correctly but um you
know these items here the human
annotators you know because it doesn't
have like the exact size match it's
considered Irrelevant for
them so yeah um and also let's you know
let's look at kind of this broad kind of
query like Just For Men what like what
is the results that are being returned
by the Baseline system and what is the
ratings that people the human aners give
so you know uh one of the relevant items
like um it's like a Visa gift card or
you know like a
joke book of jokes or like a anniversary
wallet
um uh like an anniversary card so um the
intents that is being extracted from
here is you know like for me it might
not be clear from the tokens itself but
it's mapped
to um mapped to like you know like a
gift card or you know a book that's
geared for like dads or like f figures
or or like you know Health equipments or
whatnot so uh you know this data set
again as I mentioned is pretty rich but
you know we'll just look at these are
the examples that we mainly looked at um
and we'll look at how we can how our
Baseline system performs on these
queries and how you know with like some
simple LM and prompting we can kind of
improve the results of the Baseline so
let me go back to the slides
um
so oh sorry I I showed the e-commerce
data set and I kind of showed the type
of queries that are in the data set but
I didn't show like what a simple
Baseline might actually look so what we
were looking here was um the ratings
that a human has provided um let's look
at what a simple system that elastic
search does so here with elastic search
we're just kind of matching with the
tokens we're not really doing anything
too fancy or
not
so so the system is
running um I'm just going to read the
data so the data set that we have has
like query item pairs but when we index
our items we only care about item data
we don't care about data so I'm just
getting like the product ID product
title and dropping it so again this uh
this data set has query product
relevance we only care about the product
details so today we're just going to be
focusing on the product
title so again the focus of the session
is not elastic search so we just have
some wrapper code to kind of hide some
of these things so let's take a look at
how a simple token based system might
process this query
so so we have instead of 90 shoes you
know we have Adidas shoes men 15 so
there are different ways to process a
string so here you know we have
something called an analyzer stop so if
you know like in NLP about like stop
words about removing um words that might
be that might be appearing too common um
or that are kind of very rare So in this
case um like 15 was removed because um
it's yeah it's maybe not appearing
enough in the Corpus or it's appearing
too often so um and here's another um
this is the default in elastic search
but if you notice like it does some
weird kind of stemming of the terms like
Adidas becomes Adida which you know like
the brand name is Adidas so kind of
trimming it might not make sense the
processing of shoe kind of makes sense
and this one kind of keep kept the F
size token
so um so let's look at
um so this is you know when you s the
request elastic search um for this query
you know you kind of get an array of
documents you know you get the array of
the relevant document the score and
think metadata but you know this is not
really important here let's just look at
a visual way of seeing these
results so this classic example that we
had uh first example that we looked
airpod case
cute so
um so it can happen that you know like a
human annotator might not have had time
to kind of review all the possible items
in the catalog you know for every query
you could possibly be fetching like
thousand relevant items so what this is
showing here like in our system like we
are fetching items that uh that that a
user might not have rated so you know
this this is an airport you know it is
kind of cute so it is relevant but a
human annotator didn't have didn't have
the oportunity to rate it so it's
possible to bring in um different
items um let's look at um the shoes
example from
before
so our system when it Sho sees a quaria
leader shoes men 15 because of the
tokenizer that we using like it kind of
drops 15 so the items that we are
bringing in you know they they have AER
shoes and men in the query but it
doesn't pay attention to the size so um
as we saw in the human annotated
examples like this is considered
irrelevant and uh maybe like let's look
at the final one like Just For Men so we
see like some scented candles lot of
scented candles
we see Bluetooth beanies um a lot of
cented candles and you know why are they
coming here because you know like in the
token they have like gifts for men so we
we
have items that are coming in because
they have the term gifts for men so we
don't necess necessarily see like any
unique possible gift ideas so you this
is an interesting data set if you want
to play with the Baseline you know take
a look here um we'll look at how to kind
of improve or how we can kind of improve
this kind of relevancy Gap here like for
example we have bringing in we're
bringing in like kind of relevant items
but we're not paying attention to size
so we'll see how we can use llms to help
improve that
um yeah so the takeaways you know from
the end of this section you know like I
hope uh kind of saw how like a simple
token based retrieval can work how it
might suffer from things like keyword
stuffing you know like for the gift
forment items are coming are because the
item has those tokens um you know
depending on your tokenizer you might
drop some tokens that might be important
like you know if you have specific shoe
size that you're looking for and it's
not paying attention to it
um um you know the item that you might
get might be Irrelevant for you um so
this is the end of like you know section
one kind of just um show showcasing what
the problem is um before we kind of go
to the next section of like kind of
getting an intro to llms like maybe let
me just see if there any questions
um I don't see anything in the chat so
uh hopefully um yeah the first section
that we went over was clear so let me go
over the next section so you know like
in this section we can't really cover
everything about LM so this section
we're just going to be covering over
some very high level milestones and just
like some high level brush of some Core
Concepts you know so what is an llm I
would say you know an llm is a large
language model like a newal network or a
Transformer Network that U that has
maybe like a billion plus
parameters uh it's trained on a very
large Corpus and because it's trained on
a large Corpus and also trained on like
many different tasks it can be used um
like a single model can perform like a
variety of creative things so you can
use that model for like chat Parts a
model for like generating text a model
for like generating resume so like
generating code and whatnot translating
languages uh being like
a uh like a um yeah you know helping you
edit like some graphs of like something
creative or
whatnot so this image is a bit small but
I just kind of wanted to compress all
the maybe semi big Milestones that
happened recently uh in the l space I
would say like maybe the first model
that maybe in today's standard might not
be considered a large language model but
maybe kind of set piece was built uh in
2018 from Google so that was the first
Model that had like you know several
million parameters so in this case 340
million parameters for the
large uh large U many different variants
of B but this is for a large um
parameter the large version of it so B
is an encoder which you know it's been
used for like you give it some text and
then you use it like for classification
a or like getting embeddings so whatnot
so it's not like the generative thing
that people are kind of using
today then the next big milestone was uh
2019 where there's a network P5 so maybe
the image might be too small but
basically you had one network that can
generate like four or five different
tasks but it's like translation judging
if something is relevant relevant or not
summarization you have like one model
that can do either of those tasks and
that was about 770 million
parameters so in 2020 um openai released
gpt3 um but you know that that is a
example of like a generative model right
where you're giving it some text and it
can generate
text and that model was about like 175
billion
parameters and then you know everyone is
aware of like what happened last year uh
that's when chat GPT uh with like GPT
3.5 kind of came out and partially
because of how accessible it was and the
performance of the network like that's
when I would say like the space kind of
Hit the popular
um yeah hit the popular
sphere so in 2023 of this year open a
released GPD 4 that fixed some of the
problems that were there with some the
llms things like hallucination or some
the problem other problems and uh it's
the quality of this model is also much
better um Google released their Palm 2
model in May of 2023 and you know just
recently couple of days ago they
released their new Gemini model which um
you know supposedly is beating
gp4 um so gp4 go pal they like private
models but there actually been a lot of
um research and development with open-
Source models too so in July of this
year uh meta released um several their
llama models you know 7 billion 13
billion and 70 billion models which are
all open source that you could
use so you know we talked about these
llms so how do these LMS per perform
some of these tasks right how how do you
train such a
network so I would say there's about
maybe three stages one is the
pre-training stage so these models need
a lot of lot of data so uh thankfully
you know you have the internet and you
can actually train it in an unsupervised
manner so we're talking about like a
trillion words trillion tokens so what
is the task that they're training on and
again it's in an unsupervised manner
where they're basically doing like text
completion so you know my llama 8 plus
right so you look at all the sentences
of the internet and then you're trying
to just prict the next token that might
be appearing so this is pre-training it
appears in an unsupervised manner you
can train it on a very large set of data
the next task is supervise fine tuning
so this is where you kind of need uh
labeled examples so at least you know
50,000 minimum um of where you have like
some instruction you have some input and
expected output you know so here the
instruction is write a poem about llamas
right and then you have like
uh a pair of output that you want the
model to kind of learn to
predict so this is like again in a
semisupervised manner again the model is
just trying to learn to predict the
tokens from kind of labeled examples the
final step which is what kind of is
critical to uh these chat models
performing really well is reinforcement
learning where you're basically asking
the model to kind of generate you know
like here we're generating three outputs
and then a human is kind of rating like
okay this output is relevant or not and
then you like tell the model to learn to
rank and rep prioritize its output to
generate the one that was relevant so
this reinforcement learning Keys is what
was missing and what kind of gave some
of the rise some of
the I say power of relevance of the
newer
models so one aspect about the data is
the these are these are data sets that
are used in like Facebook's llama model
so common crawl is like a data set of an
open source initiative to crawl the
internet is and it's about three
terabytes of data uh C4 is like a clean
much much cleaner version of the common
crw uh llama was find was drained on
GitHub Wikipedia stack
exchange um books is like
um uh mixture of like I think like 100k
kind of um books some of them are um
copyrighted um so that that data set is
no longer available but the basic idea
is um you can see it's like several
terabytes of data that is trained
on and if you notice also here it's
because of the size of the data set the
model only goes through the data set not
even one time right so it goes through
Wikipedia like two times um but for
other data sets it's only like a factor
one and like from an architecture
perspective the one that kind of um led
to this Evolution was the trans
transform architecture and attention is
all you need so Transformer is compos
both like an encoder and decoder so B is
an encoder but all the generative AI
kind of piece that we seeing together is
powered by
decoder and
um as you see like these days many
people are just stacking more and more
of these architectures so you know like
bir a couple of years ago was like 300
million parameters but now like we're on
billion parameters so with s such large
networks which such large data sets
which uh like efficient GPU compute
they're able to train these
networks okay so um we're training these
large networks are making these networks
larger and larger so how do you evaluate
a
network like so there are many models
you know do you use open open gp4 or do
you use know Google's Palm or Gemini or
do you use llama how do you determine
which model to
use so there is a leaderboard the chat
part Arena leaderboard that you can
click and visit and there are couple of
metrics that they have um the metric
that I that I'm most interested in is
this
Arena ELO rating so
basically what you have is like you have
some prompts you send it to like two
models and then you ask the human to
rate whether the output of one of these
models is more relevant or much
better so um it may not be a surprise
but like the top like the top the the
models that take the top spot are like
these proprietary models you know from
open Ai and like
anthropic so they have a pretty
high uh ELO scope like kind of like a
chest kind of rating but if you look a
little bit late uh sorry I do hide some
of the entries in this dashboard to kind
of emphasize some models so if you see
here you know we have llama 2 70
Bon parameters which is an open source
model and it's getting a pretty high um
e rating and um
so um The Seer 7 billion model said this
is 7 billion it's a factor of 10 smaller
it's also getting a pretty decent score
of
1042 so
Facebook kind of released the 70 billion
model 7 billion and 13B so you see like
the 7B and 13B have like 1021 but the
sephra model which is just 7 billion has
a score of like
1042 and you know just because a model
is proprietary doesn't mean that it
might do better than open source models
so this is the model from Google where
based on this rating it performs a
little bit worse than some the top
models
so we covered a lot with LMS here so
this kind of just gives like a very
broad brush of the space obviously
there's a lot of details that are not
covered but in the labs we'll kind of
see like how the how the output of this
Els actually um yeah the output of these
results for the problems that we have in
the Ecom space um before I go to the
next section let me see if there's any
question um okay so um hion has a
question about elastic search
um um yeah so yes so elastic search you
know it's a full text search engine
system it supports both um text search
and now it supports Vector search uh in
the notebook that we
saw here so like uh in in this notebook
I do have like ground root labels so for
query items so this is like um this
shows whether a human an found something
relevant for just a simple Baseline I do
have this un this relevance here just to
show like you know are we bringing in
items that are considered relevant or
not so um probably for most of these
examples that we bring we are probably
bringing in items that are different
from what Amazon's production system
brought in so most of it will be
unlabeled yeah yeah so sorry for the
possible confusion there um cool so the
we don't have a notebook for this thing
we uh it'll be combined in the next
section so let me just umly go to
um to this section so prompting section
so yeah so this section will be be short
and then we'll we'll have several
notebooks related to interacting with
our Elms so let me go
here so you know how do you talk to you
know these large language models you
know they trained on English data sets I
mean they trained on like U text
instructions so you can talk to it
basically like in PL text um and the
beauty of this is you know you
can
um you can if you're detailed in your
instructions you can get kind of get it
to um output like output powerful um
powerful
results so let's consider you know but
there's still some kind of small art in
kind of generating like a valid kind of
set of
instructions
so in a prompt I would say there's maybe
like four pieces so one is like you kind
of give a role so um if you if you like
um if you're looking for like the output
to be generated in a certain tone or
like the model to consider certain
domain knowledge like if you have like a
role as kind of like your first prefix
of your prompt the model might um the
model might acknowledge that and kind of
like output results in
a relevant to then you have the typical
instructions again the RO is optional
though most people might just start with
instructions
here so here the sample prompt you know
we have classified a below medical news
as healthy or
concerning so then you have some input
text you know the um some some medical
test here and then you have output and
this the output here is what you want
the model to
generate
um sometimes depending on the type of
problem you might want to give your
model some examples like if you want it
to return in a certain way or a certain
output format or you wanted to maybe
give an explanation in a certain tone or
a certain manner you can provide like
input pairs input output pairs so in
this example here we have two input
output Pairs and then we have
final final example where we want the
model to generate an
example um the other kind of prompting
thing is you know the model is kind of
trained to generate the next token but
maybe be because of that it might
sometimes be greedy and it might
generate a token that might not be
completely valid so this is like a
reasoning exercise here so if you take a
look at this example we have a juggler
can juggle 16 balls and half of the
balls are golf balls and half of those
golf balls are blue and the question is
how many blue golf balls are there so we
have 16 balls half of them are golf
balls so we have eight golf balls and we
know half of those eight are blue so
that means we have four um we have four
um four ball we have four golf balls
that are blue but the model maybe
because it didn't pay attention to part
of the context it greedily answer eight
so sometimes depending on your task you
could add things like you know explain
your reasoning or let's think step by
step or whatnot and this will just allow
the model to kind of um uh reason a
little bit better before it kind of
outputs an
explanation
um we won't really cover too much here
but there are some parameters that you
can use to control the um the output of
a prompt so all these all the models
have these kind of common parameters
about like whether to kind of readily
choose the most relevant token or to
sample from only the top relevant tokens
stuff like that we won't really be
playing with these parameters directly
in the lab um but just something to
think about depending on your task
whether you wanted to kind of do it
whether you want it to be like a coile
in like a creative task or kind of more
like a structured riger
task so um we we have three notebooks
here um I will be covering one of the
notebooks and then my colleague Mr um
covered other two let me share my scre
let me go to the next
notebook so we have three prompting
notebooks
um um actually maybe four sorry we have
like a intro prompting notebook which
I'll be covering where we'll be showing
how you can use something like line
chain to talk to
um uh talk to different llm uh providers
and we'll also see some of the examples
of like um zero shot and few
shot so let me
um yeah let me just run this
again
so um I do have some of the LM outputs
cach
so when we run this notebook it'll just
be a little bit faster and the cache is
also saved um inside the repo so if you
decide to run this uh notebook
externally because there's the cache you
don't necessarily need to like create an
API key with all these different
vendors so the first use case that we'll
be covering is just like a reasoning
task and let's start with like um you
know kind of the best model out there
which is open AI GPD 4 so uh GPD 4
supports like different context links so
we're just using the default which
supports like a input length of 8,000
for the use case that we have here you
know we not providing like very very
large inputs so we'll just stick with
the default for today
so I have a template here where I'm
going to ask a question I'm going to
provide this as a variable and I expect
a model to generate an answer so again
I'm just going to cover this is heavily
using line chain partially because of
it's cashing and then partially because
I think it makes it easier to interact
with different llm
vendors so um here's just a template you
know string we have these variables here
I have a input varable question so let
me and I have this question you know can
Barack Obama have a conversation with
George
Washington if I use like line change
prom to format it um it
automatically um replace the question
here
and um yeah so we initialized the uh
Lang chain has a way of like sequencing
you know different chains or different
sequence of activ but in our case today
we just going to be prompting the model
directly we won't be doing any fancy
stuff
so
um so when when I make a call to the
model to run something like I have this
question here um the underlying Library
kind of adds this like uh role here like
okay it's the human that's asking this
question and let's see what it generated
here
so um so okay so here we see that you
know
the there was about 22 tokens in the
input and there were about 23 output
tokens that were
generated and it cost about like 0.02
cents so and this is the response that
came from the LM no it's not possible um
because George Washington Pass in a
certain age yep so this this is the
output from
gbd4 um you know you can make a prompt
request uh to the open API and kind of
figure how much tokens are there or the
tokenizer that is used by open AI is
available
so
um so you know for this query here we
see like this is how the how the input
was
tokenized yeah and so you can do a count
there so we saw the response from openi
so let's look the response from another
proprietary model so this is Google's uh
pal
model so um it does seem to take some
time so um let's just look at the
response that we already reg generated
so um response did come
so it gives like the correct answer you
know it's not possible again same thing
like chat GPD because it considers when
a person died and was born but then it
kind of like I wouldn't say this as
hallucination but it kind of gets into
some creative answer you know like
Barack Obama can have a digital
conversation um I mean a conversation
with a digital representation of
Washington and um you know with text to
speech and whatnot you know you can kind
of do something realistic so it kind of
goes into some of the creative aspect of
the
answer
um and then like Barack Obama can have a
conversation with medium such as V board
or C so it does it does I wouldn't say
it's hallucination it does get into this
like some creative response
here so um let's look at the sephr model
you know this is the 7 billion model
which is open
source
so um yeah so here we using hugging face
Hub so hugging face so the model is in
hugging face and hugging face kind of
provides like a free end point to kind
of run some things so the inference is
not running locally but from L chain if
you wanted you can uh assuming you have
all the dependencies and the infro you
can use like hugging face uh pipelines
to kind of run the inference
locally so it does takes some time here
so um again because it might be like
scaling up dynamically play for the
request
um maybe while this is running
um maybe I'll just wait a couple of
seconds here um so again this is like
the open source open source model that
was trained by hugging f um and it's
only 7 billion parameters so the
response we get um no Barack Obama
cannot have a conversation conversations
can only happen between living
beings so um I would say like open Ai
and saffer kind of provided the most
Rec most current response like Google's
Palm was being maybe a bit too creative
and maybe that might be like those
default par parameters with like
temperature and whatnot that Google
exposes so
um running llama can be a little bit
expensive um or might be a little bit
difficult locally we may need like gpus
and whatnot um but but I found this
serverless um provider for like um
running for making requests ad hoc
request to some the Llama models so
Facebook released like three three
parameter sizes you know 7 billion 13
billion and 70 billion and then they
release like the base model and then
like the
instruction uh tuned uh versions of
those models so let's see how these
models perform for the same
request so um I'm just maybe in the
interest of time I'm just going to show
the output here so for this prompt here
like we see the output is like it's
returning a list you know strong no
strong yes so it return two answers so
uh you know yes if you're talking to the
actual person but then uh yes it's
possible if you're talking about like
the talking about um like a founding F
kind of stuff um
so I think this answer kind of
hallucinated a little bit like
it I'm not sold by this explanation here
so this is the 7 billion base model um
the chat
model um you know it's like okay this is
an interesting hypothesis okay but in
the end it's
um um it kind of gives a relevant answer
but you see like already with like it
directly answer the question right it's
uh it answers okay yeah they B in
different time zones but you know we
kind of stopped it early like it's just
kind of talking a little bit um
so um yeah so this is this was the 7
billion model so let's look at the uh 13
billion model um the 13 billion model
you know like um you know it responded
kind of quickly no they B live at
different
times um the chat base model again
um like it's kind of hypothesizing a
little bit and kind of coming up with
slightly different response here
so um yeah maybe in the so this is the
70 billion model let's look at the 70
billion chat model so again we see the
chat model is kind of rambling a little
bit and not
um maybe not giving the answer in the
shortest cleanest way like as open Ai
and
sapper
so it's a this is like kind of the
reasoning case let's actually look at
the
um like the like the subject for this
case the e-commerce use case here so the
examples that we'll be looking here is
kind of dealing with like the vocabulary
vocabulary Gap problem so um
the idea is you know you have maybe like
an item title but it doesn't have tokens
that a user might be searching for so
can we use a large language model to
generate um queries that a user might be
searching for if they came to this
item so uh let's just set debugging
false and then so the um the use Keys
again is given an item title we want to
generate queries that a user might uh
search for
so the the sample item tile that we'll
be playing with is you know this
biodegradable bamboo natural charcoal
toothbrush eco-friendly sustainable and
it's a definitely like a stuffing of um
words here so let's see the um let's see
how it performs with just zero shot
prompting so here you know we we just
provide a use case we don't
provide any examples and let's see how
how it performs
so um again so this is a prompt you know
you're given a title generate two
possible search
queries and um this is the response that
we get from open AI which I think is
pretty good you know ecofriendly
toothbrushes pack of six and two
composable travel toothbrush with soft
bristles so this response is relevant um
but if you notice like um this output is
just like a string and you know there's
one and do it's not like a way that is
easily
possible
so um what we're going to do in the
prompt is like we going to tell it we
want the response to be generated as
like a comma separated list so again L
kind of makes it easy we have our
regular prompt template we have our
input variables and we can provide like
instructions here so let's just run this
here and just can look look at the
prompt so um you know we added format
instructions here uh Lang chain has like
some
automatic um instructions that it adds
here so you know it see your response
should be a list of comma separated
values so we do the same prompt here but
then we also send the response to the
parser
so at first clance it kind of looks
right but if you notice like we do have
partially invalid tokens I mean
partially invalid output so here like we
have it in strings but then we have like
a quote here and a quote here so the
model didn't really generate output in
the correct
manner so to kind of help this thing
here a little bit um I noticed that if I
just say like hey you're an ecommer
shopping assistant and I do the same
prompt uh just adding this line it
generates the output um in a much easily
possible
manner but I think in general like when
you when new prompt and like you want
outputs for kind of like your system or
for use case it's good to always provide
some examples so here you know we have
our role we have our prompt uh and then
we have some examples so I say like
here's here's this you know Pokemon
Special complete ediction edition
sorry and then we have like two queries
that we generated from the logs so this
is based on the engagement data that we
saw from the data that Amazon has um but
you come up with your own create so here
I'm just providing uh two examples and
then I'm
asking I'm running the same promt
again and again I would get this I would
expect the same results but it's just
much easier to
PA so this is like with openi model so
let's look at
um let's look at the open source model
from Facebook the Llama
model so one thing is the llama model
The Prompt is a little bit different so
what you need to do is like you have an
instruction here like you need to have
the instruction tag then you have the
system prompt you have the user message
and then end of the instruction
tag so um if we take our existing prompt
like so we have the system prompt we
e-commerce shopping assistant listed
here
then um we have this this whole thing is
like the um user message
here so um yeah I'm running maybe a bit
short on times let me just look at the
rendered output here so
um so let's look at the results so this
is using the Llama 7 billion model here
so we see it's just kind of generating
like some code is not relevant at
all uh if I look at the 7 billion chat
model like it's not generating like it's
generating queries for the stample I
provided not for the one that I wanted
to
provide so 7 billion is pretty small I
guess um but if I use yep so it's not
working so the 13 billion model again
I've noticed like the regular the
regular non chat based models they just
kind of seem to want to generate
code and the 13 billion chat model we
are starting to get relevant stuff so it
says it kind of gives a veros response
but it does generate like Eco to brush
travel to
brush um if you look at um again the 70
billion model not a chat based model but
we see that it again it's not Shing code
but it's not really relevant here but
the 70 billion chat model it generates
um um queries that are relevant and also
gives an explanation about why the item
might be
relevant so
um yeah so maybe for the final thing I
wanted to show like The Open Source
models eort again this is 7 billion and
um the same prompt and these are the
queries that it gave so it gave the
queries and it gave us explanation so
this 7 billion model open source model
is doing better than um
like the Llama 7 billion and the Llama
13 billion
model so just the sorry we covered a lot
here um so just you know the takeaway um
from this notebook is you
know uh L chain kind of makes it very
easy to interact with um different llm
options there um we can see that LMS are
pretty good
reasoning uh definitely gp4 is like if
you can if paying the cost you know it
seems to perform the
best um if you want the output in a
certain format you know like doing few
shop CR thing is
important and um even like smaller model
7 billion model can perform well so so
this is um this is the first notebook
that we have in now my colleague muster
will be showing how
to how using prompting we can solve like
two other two other cases that we talked
about so let me stop sharing and give it
to
him hi everyone um so in this notebook I
will uh talk about how we are using the
how we using the large language models
to understand the uh queries and the
product
so in previous notebooks uh Nan talked
about a simple token matching uh search
system like uh think about a a bm25
model that uh that uses a like bag of
wordss logic tries to match the tokens
of the query to tokens extracted from an
item uh and scores these uh tokens token
matches and ranks the items by some way
but notice that it doesn't pay attention
to the the attributes or the the meaning
of the query or the attributes of the
item at all so it's basically just a
token match and scoring those uh the
matches with some waiting and it ranks
the items but assume that you have a
system that you can actually understand
your items extract your attributes of
those items and uh and index them
somehow and when you query come to your
system you also extract the attribute of
the query and try to match in a smarter
way so I will show in this notebook how
we can do it with an U with llm with
prompting um so let's
just sure let's get it
done
uming environment
everything so this is basically just uh
in an Ecommerce setting we are in this
part we are trying to set uh we are only
going to check couple of attributes of
the products for for this notebook only
in in in a general use case in
e-commerce they're definitely looking
more than four five attributes but for
this notebook only you will check couple
of them like product type brand gender
color and size so this is just for
output formatting I'll I'll just going
to skip this fast um so let's look look
at the promp okay uh so this is a uh fot
prompt okay in a fot prompt U most of
you know you provide some examples to
llm and to uh to help the llm put in a
put in a state that it can extract the
it can U extract the attributes in a
better way so in a general way we use
that you are an e-commerce expert your
task is to extract attributes from a
customer query and possible attributes
are prodct type brand gender color and
size okay then we provide the examples
here so the first example is yellow 35
in baseball bat so we say uh there's no
brand in this quy there is no gender in
this quy the product type of this uh C
is baseball bats that means the customer
is only looking for baseball bats the
color is black and size is 35
inch um and the second example is some
kind of man's waterproof ski jacket
and we extract another brand gender
product type color size we say none for
them and we provide the uh the the quer
is input here and some other formatting
instructions are there so in uh let's
run this um first format our query so uh
this is going to be our our prompt for
the Nike man shoes we will expect LM to
generate an output and the output is
going to be in this
format uh so let's do that uh let's
actually make this
firstes so as you see the can extract
the the brand as Nike gender as male
product type as shoes color green and
there's no size intent in it so uh we
can do the same thing for this is for
query only uh we can do the same thing
for the product type
products so as you see the the LM
generated the brand is mang gender is
male and notice that the LM generalized
the men to a male uh by using the uh by
using the dictionary that we provided
there and product type is a ski jacket
uh there no color intent and then
there's no size in it so so um so think
of think of this this way Lo so your
index is most likely is going to be
static or it's going to change very uh
minimally uh you can update it every
couple of hours or a couple days
depending on your scale of your system
so you can extract the your attributes
in some way by using llms and when the
query comes you try to match in a smart
way to the items so this is one use case
that you can solve the uh
uh the the token matching uh going from
token matching to understanding the
query and you you can improve your
system in some
way the one other notebook I will
present in here is going to be um
understanding the relevancy of the the
query to un items uh so if you have a
search system you what you want to do is
most of time you want to understand how
your system is doing like uh when you
present a query like or change your
algorithm uh how is your system is
changing so usually uh what is done
right now is or what is done in couple
of years back is um the queries uh the
queries some queries are selected from
the systems and some items are extracted
by by using these queries and the manual
annotators are going over these query
item pairs manually and scoring them as
IR relevant non-relevant or they can use
some um ranking scale from one to five
depending on the uh system like zero as
non-relevant or one as somewhat relevant
two three four five five is perfect
maybe uh but right now we can use llms
to generate that
data uh let's let me do this in this
one okay a problem in here anyway I
generated some of them before so uh
let's let's see couple of prompts in
here this is a zero shot prompt that we
don't show any example to the system
what we are saying is this you are an
helpful e-commerce assistant and you
will judge relevancy of an item to a
query and respond in one of the three
options below so we are only providing
three options to llm to judge the uh
relevancy of the item to a given query
we are saying the first one is relevant
if the item is relevant to the query
second partial relevant if the item is
somewhat relevant to the query and
irrelevant if the item is not relevant
to the query and and uh in a oneshot
example we are helping the llm by
providing an example um the the example
query in here is they're saying 30 30 o
tumbler with a handle and one shot item
is some 30 o tumbler with a handle some
extra tokens there uh and we are
providing the qu and item
description um we are asking U the gp4
uh to judge the relevance of item to the
query so let's see the first
example uh we we askas choose man's
choose size 15 and the item is actually
contains those tokens as well um ad
shoes with size 15 and some extra tokens
there uh and the answers as IR relevant
but notice we also ask the reasoning of
what why you're answering it as a
relevant okay so the lam MERS in this
way uh the lam finds the the the size
intent in it by size 15 the brand is
matching and the gender of the item is
also matching to the qu so it is um it
is answering is as a
relevant and we are changing the item
this time we're asking um same query
within
um different size okay this time LM
answers it as a partial relevant because
uh it thinks that uh the size difference
can be a partial relevance uh we saw in
the previous example in the the manual
annotators Amazon manual annotators mark
them as nonrelevant but uh lmers as a
partial relevant so uh we will show like
the fine-tuning of the llms so you can
somehow use this manual data to
fine-tune your model to make your model
to answer instead of partial relevant
you can make it as uh you can make can
make it answer as a non-relevant it's we
will explain that in the in one more uh
another notebook so uh the other example
is um this a non-relevant example the
item we changed item completely right
now it is a hiking Woods for women and
size nine and this time llm answers as
irrelevant and it explains the reasoning
because that the the brand is not
matching the gender is not matching and
the size is not matching so it's an
irrelevant
item so we can do harder example this
was this these two these three was kind
of easy
we can ask gifts for men so think about
the system when you provide a gifts for
men to your system in a token match
sense okay uh it's so hard to come up
with uh come up with uh examples or
results there because it will only try
to match gift and token gifts and Men
tokens in your system so uh so in this
time we when we give the gifts for men
and the item to the um uh to the
llm so the item is the meril hiking
boots for women and size nine and it
answers are irrelevant because uh the
reasoning is uh reasoning explains by
itself actually it says that it's a pair
of uh wom's hiking boots and it's not
relevant to uh C user query the second
example is uh the same quod again we are
providing the item as um virus
controller for PlayStation 4 and lm's
reasoning is relevant and it says uh
this can be decent present gift for a
man and the um one last example was uh
we are providing a pat insulin syringes
this is completely irrelevant and uh LM
answers as irrelevant and provides this
as uh
irrelevant um and it's provides it
reasoning as a why it's an irrelevant
item so uh so one use case of this uh
relevancy judgment can be evaluation
this is very useful
uh you can save lots of cost by by
skipping the uh manual labor and it's uh
also very uh it's going to reduce to
timing um because uh when human
annotators are work on these tasks it
takes lots of time to for them to
generate uh answers third one is scale
you can uh you can judge lots of queries
and lots of items by this way and um uh
one other use case can be uh you can use
this kind of data for learning to rank
so uh when you have you can generate
this kind of relevancy information you
can use this these kind of relevance
relance payers Square item payers to
train your rank models and make your
system
better um I'll go back to the
slides so in this part I'll talk about
how to fine tune the LM models so uh so
we have now LM models uh out there they
can do many tasks in a great way but uh
think of a use case that you want to uh
make it special for your for your for
your uh use case Okay um so if you wanna
if you want to uh if if you need a model
you can do you can train your model by
ground up that will take
that will take lots of time and you will
spend lots of money on it so um and in
order to skip this step you can
fine-tune this model um with a very
small data set relatively small data set
compared to original data sets that
that's provided to this the train to Big
LM models and this model can also better
uh perform better than the generic LM
models um and also we can you it can use
use the the lm's learnings or uh its
knowledge in the know its weights to
generalize your task better um and
transfer the knowledge that it already
contains to your task um and you will
not have much of privacy concerns and
you will also own the um own the IP of
the um the fine tuned
model so what kind of problems you may
have faced with when you're fine tuning
so one of the biggest problem is the
data collection uh uh so and the quality
of the data you need to provide a good
quality and and some um good quality
data to get a to get a decent decent llm
model and one other problem is uh
overfitting and catastrophic forgetting
this this happens when you train your
models like
uh over overt Trin your model and and
somehow uh your model weights are um
updated in a way that the the knowledge
that it it already contains in the base
model um uh changed and your uh your
model is not able to generate uh do do
generalization anymore and because it it
fits to your data that you provided a
lot um then you so uh so you you lose
most of the capabilities of L at that
point uh the other problem is the
computational resources because these
are big models uh they need lots of GPU
and um and computing power um uh so um
even for fine tuning you might face
these kind of problems um uh also the
other problems can be uh lack of
interoperability uh this is actually a
very uh big problems for the generic
neural network models but uh
uh you may face with these kind of
problems as well um and one not lastly U
so these L mods are uh instruction tuned
so U when you train your model in a way
in in a way if your model if your input
data is not in a set in a good way you
will have problems with instruction
tuning as
well so uh let's think about U
relatively small Al model 7 billion
parameters um uh a 7 billion parameter
Al model we think about uh two bytes of
per parameter for the weights or four
bytes per parameter for Optimizer state
two bytes per parameter for gradients
and in total you will need 52 52
gigabytes of memory to just uh uh to
fine tune your model and we ignore some
of the other things like bat size
sequence length and others so in order
to solve these problems uh couple of
years ago um these smartman on the top
right uh they they introduced the Laura
low rank adaptation for L LMS what is
happening in Laura is um they freeze the
pretrain M weights and they inject some
trainable rank matrices so think ofam as
a big Matrix that is D byd okay uh I'm
simplifying everything here so and uh
what they did was they they just uh
partitioned this two um the smaller
matrices that are trainable and they
train they train the matrices instead of
updating whole weights of the llm so
think about this W as Frozen weights uh
and only these smaller mates are
trained so um some uh let me show
Laura's performance in some of the tasks
um so the uh the are direct taken from
the paper uh gpt2 the gpd2 medium fully
fine fine-tuned without Laura okay it
fine tunes over 300 million parameters
and and with Laura this number of
parameters dropped to35 million in this
uh just check the blue score its score
is better than the fully fine tune model
and um you can check the fully fine tune
in gp22 large as well um the blue score
is uh again it's uh this better one
better better than the fifine tun
version of it so uh but this found is
mostly with Laura you can U you can at
least get performance on par with full
Define tun
models so uh one of the IP parameters of
Laura is the the rank parameter um so
improving the rank uh increasing the
rank parameter uh will have benefit in
the performance of your uh fine tun
model but this this Improvement plateus
after some level um and uh and for some
data sets lower rank also performs
better uh there's a new other version of
the uh Laura that is qua u in this this
version um the the Improvement was done
on the memory requirements u in contest
Laura um uh conation is done in 4bit
normal float Precision um and one
another benefit of Kora is um they use
double quantization that um saves
further it's like quation of the quation
actually it says like 337 bits per
parameter um uh they also introduced
like uh page optimizers uh uh to to
prevent some memory spikes and uh K is
uh K lets you train your Mo fine-tune
your model with less uh Hardware
requirements so how you shape your data
for fine-tuning so uh think of your
system is again in in you want to find
you in an instruct instructive way so
you provide your uh data in a shape of
the prompts you you provide your uh
question and answer you can say in a
question answer um so let's say for if
you if you are fine-tuning our model to
just predict the uh predict the prot
type of
uh query um your your input is classify
prot type of this query you provide your
query and you provide answer and you let
your Alum to predict and compare your
answer to the label and uh do all these
um uh gradient des and
Etc uh for the lab nin is going to
continue uh with fine tuning
example uh yeah so we running a little
bit low on time so maybe I'll just share
the results and then kind of go over the
very few remaining slides so um
so I just wanted to show the results for
you know like for this query you know
Nike black men shoes if we use the you
know attribute extraction case that most
ofer mentioned you know we do get prodct
type shoes brand Nike all that so with
GPD 4 kind of works well and um if you
if you just do like the Llama base model
or the Llama base bottle you know it
starts it generates some stuff but then
it generates like other kind of
enrollment so what we did is like we
just fine tuned a model like on the
instruction Ts that mosta shared but we
use like gp4 to generate the uh training
data and then we kind of send the same
query and this is the output from our
fine tune llama 7B
model um yeah so let me just quote like
three slides to kind
of tie like some final things together
and then if any questions um
so so you know we come a lot so I just
want to kind of tie some of the things
that you mentioned you know a user comes
to like e-commerce site they have a
query you know like gift for men it kind
of might be ambiguous so you might have
like an llm or some type of model to
kind of help rewrite it to extract the
queries in a more understandable manner
right and then you might have like the
attribute LM kind of model to extract
the intents to query the same model you
might you might be running on the item
side
here and then you know you can use your
elastic search you know the full text
search or vector search or whatnot to
kind of retrieve these candidates so the
model that kind of extracts intents you
kind of annotate your items with those
intents too so then you can use elastic
search kind of like matching on product
type or whatnot or whatever system so
you kind of get all these candidates
then you can kind of use an llm to kind
of uh see if something is relevant or
not so here we use llms kind of for all
these kind of four use cases but you
know you can also use LMS for training
data and then you know train much
cheaper model
so I just wanted to share like other
places where this kind of architecture
or where LMS are being used in the Ecom
scenario so Shopify I think like um
couple of weeks ago they had a blog post
about how they allowed their Merchants
to kind of generate product descriptions
So based on like some keywords that they
generate that the that the merchant puts
in their form and then it uses some
large language model to kind of generate
product
descriptions um you know we we talked
about this ambiguous query so from
instacart you know if you have something
like you know what pairs well with Salon
um like in the first image you have like
things that have like salmon in the
keyword but that may not be kind of
relevant you know what be for with
salmon is like seasoning lemon or what
not so this is kind of where they using
an llm to help extract the intent I mean
help reformulate or understand the qu
and then show results for
that and um you know this Workshop was
kind of inspired from a paper from Etsy
where they basically showed this use
case of using llama that they fine tune
on their Corpus to kind of you know
extract uh extract a product type here
or to extract like what the user is
searching for or extract rewriting the
query so this Workshop was kind of
inspired by this s um from this paper
from Etsy so this is the last slide that
we have and I just kind of want to share
the results from one from etsy's paper
here so their instruction was you know
um which category I'm going to give you
a query which category is this query in
so the query is Himalayan salt lamp and
the corre answer is home and living so
GPD 3.5 you know it has its own kind of
taxonomy understanding so it said home
and Liv
um so the the Llama 7B which you know um
this is not fine you you know you see
it's kind of very wose it's kind of
giving like it's not it's giving not
just the answer it's giving some other
stuff the 30b parameter model um gives
the corre answer but it doesn't match
the casing of internally etc's tonomy
but the fine tune model that Etc did you
know seven even the 7B kind of gave the
gave it in the format that Etsy was um
looking for so you know this is kind of
the last slide that we had here so sorry
there was a lot of material here but I
just wanted to show you know like
um like in an e-commerce scenario you
know there's at least couple of problems
like understanding the query ambiguous
queries understanding the intent of the
items relevancy and just show how you
can use something like llms to kind of
help tackle these problems without you
know training like any expensive models
or whatnot um yeah so that was the last
slide that me let me see if there any
questions um I would say like this is an
example of like retrial augmented
generation so you have like a query
you're using like
a um LM to kind of rewrite the intent
and then you can kind of go through the
normal kind of search flow like you know
you could just rewrite the query and
then directly use elastic search or
whatnot or you can kind of use LMS and
um help solve these problems uh I think
like in a production system because
latency is kind of a concern like uh
it's very expensive to use like llms in
for solving all these problems um in our
case like we use like caching so uh
that's why it seem like the response
came pretty quickly otherwise you know
like gp4 or what not could take like a
second or so um yeah so it could be
expensive to run real
time and the slides are in our repos you
know so if you feel if you want to and
we also have a contact ino in the first
few slides so you know please feel free
to reach out um thank you